I don't know all right ready
come everyone i know this talk came
about relatively short notice but it's a
good to see actually the folks i was
hoping would would be here are so that's
great and it gives me a great pleasure
to welcome to ohsu someone I've known
for a long time and who also happens to
be in town because some of you know chip
Moceri who's going into this semi well I
guess retirement mode net total
retirement but anyways anyway so I'd
like to introduce Frank naymeer ad who's
the chief executive officer and chairman
of the board and co-founder of a company
called intelligent medical objects which
is based in the Chicago area some of you
may have heard of them they actually
employ one of our graduates and also one
of our longtime students who has been in
the lifetime student category but she
does great work for them and actually
this isn't the first company that Frank
founded he found another company called
intelligent medical systems which was
sold to glaxo in 1994 he's a member of
numerous organizations in the field
author and co-author of several
publications his degrees are from
Southern Illinois University and
Illinois Institute of Technology the
latter being a PhD in computer science
and he did his thesis work focused on
medical vocabulary to support database
translation information retrieval
intelligent medical records and expert
systems and Frank has a very interesting
vision for bringing semantics to medical
data and I always enjoy hearing him talk
so i'll enjoy hearing the latest
incarnation so i will turn it over to
him III guess want one last thing before
we start I would point out given the
late nature we may not have any people
out there but we are streaming this as
we stream all of our videos and I'll we
actually take questions by Twitter so
monitor the twitter feed and we may get
a question from out there but if not I'm
sure there'll be plenty of questions
here although I'm informed that we need
to wrap up by about 10 45 because we
were able to squeeze into this classroom
today so thank you very much i also have
Regis charlo our president our CTO I
asked you use to join me and be
available during the quest Q&A and so we
just will be available especially if
some technical questions come well thank
you thank you very much and I hope this
can make a interesting experience I'm
going to be really focusing on next
generations of innovation on the a chai
tea and the concept called semantic
highway that that I hope I can get
through and I think at same time really
go over some of the challenging and
opportunities for new ventures basically
virtual Commerce I feel like to really
make something come alive you range that
some I attached dollar amount or so
people can make money on it if you can
David if people can make money I think
that's going to be great this would be
given by basically myself and we just
shallow so I think you know what's
important is first to kind of give you a
little more background about ourselves
well before I said I want to kind of go
take you back about 2,500 years ago okay
the first first so-called multi-nation
country was done by a person called
Cyrus who invaded and free the Jews send
the juice to Bob to build the temple as
well as he made created this really a
completely exciting a Empire which
allowed people to do trade if you look
at the first police and you see the
statues that were developed there
they're actually taking gifts then I'll
really give to just commerce they do in
commerce and one of the things he did he
create his outpost and these outputs
were really created to allow a trusted
model so one outputs posts could talk to
another outdoor scene he sent two
messengers every day you go from one
location to another location so he
didn't just create these infrastructure
of Commerce without balancing check and
and trust so he knew of
going on so I believe that's exactly
what needs to happen to a chai tea we
need to know what's going on and we need
to understand what's being collected his
guessing game has to go away and if we
can successfully achieve that we will be
able to then basically if you overcome
the challenge well let me tell you later
about our company so obviously really
the most important part is is that
really we we have been that the
innovation the clinical interest to end
of his term internet fish terminology
meaning you know instead of calling the
synonyms we just actually take every
sentence every term has a unique
identifier and then and it lives within
its own universe and we started
releasing the our products in 1995 year
after our company was incorporated and
and immediately there's those same
identifiers from 1995 the same identify
given to each of the terms each of the
descriptions really we are about quoting
been together since then I think you
know from if you really look at even
some of our our partners are coming back
dr. Andy Kanter who's really spin
someone you probably know a very active
in in milling and millennium village he
walked into Columbia as well he left IMO
and he just back again to help us again
it's really almost like a family trip
Masseria is good example and we hope
that we can extend the family it's not
because the big responsibility I mean it
we need qualified people to be there we
have significant footprint you know
obviously most of the electronic medical
records are trusting us in your
terminology but majority of them are
loop has been toric lee been looking at
us as a billing and reimbursement
mapping we have over 350,000 physician
users and in estimator close to right
now about that thing for about 3800
hospitals in a country using one or you
know there are our services we price our
product very low so I mean and that's
really our objective is to really help
the transformations activities we are
moving to international very heavily but
our primary objective for international
is to increase the reach and capability
of our electronic medical record partner
like epic Cerner meditech all script as
they go into those countries we try to
be in that countries to support them
there's
not that much opportunity there but
there will be opportunity because the
commerce that we believe it is going to
happen later on is going to happen true
epic is going to happen through meditech
is going to happen to cerner and that's
what i feel that what our
responsibilities to make sure that as
they go to other countries we can also
support it and obviously it's very
important for you to note there is not a
nehi tea company that i know of that
half of the board of directors are MDS
and it half the board of directors are
not just a regular md's these are really
innovative endings dr. andy counter is a
board director you know is active in
from addis asst like a Charlie saffron
is an art director he was chairman of a
mia and that dr. David tracer was really
my partner in my first company that we
sold it was a Dean of medical school as
well as worked a lot of stuff in
severity assessment modeling modeling
and dr. Kim Meyer who has really has
come up and had this patent on this
concept called problem solving engine he
believes you go to a doctor to solve
your problem so he said we need to
understand how to solve the problem is
solved and I'm be able to cap
encapsulated so again this is very
important for you to understand that
structure allows me to be stay focused
in our mission to help the clinicians
and activity there our mission and
visions are on our website and you can
clearly understand or see and feel what
what we are about we're really looking
for info Mattison's that can come to our
company we doubled in size in employee
if you have an hour 160 employees right
now just last year around we hired 16
for mattresses majority of them were MDS
and informatics people and we expect to
fire 50 more this year again this is
because of the magnitude of
responsibility that we have in the
marketplace we are expert and we want to
support innovation and help
commercialization of informatics
innovations so all right what we're
going to talk about today obviously
we're going to go very quickly on
definitions of role of medical
terminology how we see it role of
adoptions of interface terminology and
how it really increased I mean I would
just kind of focus on how do we go from
going from just
vendor or client by client into really
massively increasing our footprint and
that whole aspects of how that happen
and why and I can tell you what the
success story was and again the whole
objective here is just in time
terminology things change can we respond
to that and bring into the forefront and
then really hope semantic highway and
why I believe that says you know really
innovation foundations and then need for
what I call semantic grid and that's why
I'm here I believe the academic centers
really need to be leading those those
trading outputs that i was talking to
you it has to really have the factories
in academic centers so one thing
discoveries happen in academic centers
then you should be able to be packaged
up and going to trading outpost like
epic and be able to realize a for that
academic center for that innovator so
they can actually monetize that so again
we believe the foundation of of EHR is
the terminology and terminology which
will be based on a concept based
architecture and as you can see the way
you know the way we identify is that the
fact that you say mi heart attack in
myocardial infarctions they really have
same meaning so they have to really go
to the same concept and so when people
start building their own synonym and if
those synonyms are not really mapped to
those concept I'm sorry we just lost
that very important point of reference
and we feel that those point of
reference has to be maintained we have
to actually have some argument around us
some aspects so you know well is the
breast cancer and cancer breasts are
same we say you know what you know you
know you could say the same but when I
talked to my wife was your gynecologist
said well you know Frank when I say
breast cancer I'm really really not
breast cancer when I am I know say
cancer breast is actually I'm managing
that perimeter cancer so again what that
means is that we cannot take that
lexical variance lightly we need to
respect that now we may not put in our
search engine to show both of them but
in whichever case we want to make sure
that that term that concept is
maintained so when you later on the
discovery on the lawn tional aspects of
the care you can then understand what
that physician was thinking and you can
probably learn not only from that
position
but foreign concept as well together I
believe it's really exciting exciting
phenomenon happening again you are very
familiar with all the different coding
system because of our international
involvement we are actively involved by
c10 wh 0 IC 10 CA arstan australia it is
amazing it is amazing as we go to these
countries how they are looking at us
they're looking at the United States and
asking guys where are you going we want
to be there we want to follow you except
Germany that's all but Germany's kind of
has its own philosophy which is really
interesting we trying to get into that
this because but but other than that
everybody else are really looking up to
what's happening in us and they want to
follow and i think i would say this is a
very very very excited timeframe for
informatics a primary objective for IMO
is right now to capture and preserve the
clinical intent that's the most
important things and as soon as you go
and parse the data and identify some
tokenization so identify self concept
capture that and preserve it in a full
version and identifications that has
mapped at that point in time again you
know the fact that pharmacy you know you
have this CR OS and EHRs and pharmacies
have three different coding system /
same thing one is looking at it true NDC
one is looking through midre what is
looking at through you know our x norm
again these are all aspects that has to
be normalized and I think what National
Library medicine has done which is truly
innovative I think Betsy Humphrey by
four has been one of the most innovative
person in the country I believe but
bringing about the National Library of
Medicine identifying the standards and
making sure people understand and get
access to the standards we do not I
emily has no intent to create new
standards our objectives to make the
standards work and as the standards
becomes better our mapping will to them
will become better again that is the
foundation of our strategy so what we
feel that as as these standards for
laboratory and medications and
administration in the become more
sophisticated will map to them
normalize them what we want we want that
physician to say what they want to say
and not have to be a coder not become a
code of dashi code this stuff all right
I think there are different you know
type of terminology and I think the most
important was is that we are primary
objectives in a first Jim knowledge okay
now what is the interface terminology it
is a cross map of the various code set
and medical terminology to allow the
capture of structured clinical
information from the provider again
there's a lot of innovation around
terminology is still happening and we
hope that we can by mapping to that
bring those innovations also to the
point service again it's all about
connecting to that concept connecting to
that groupers connecting to those value
sets and then be actually making it
workable at point of service and a point
and analytics well icd-10 turned
everybody kind of upside down for a
while obviously so the whole concept of
going from you know 13 or 15 thousand
icd-9 code to 65,000 icd-10-cm code is
absolutely amazing and really being able
to create an initial map Jim map that
was distributed if we did not do a favor
you know actually expose things that was
that actually in many cases which result
in this delay again because people
cannot be ready it's just really
difficult many of our clients going to
be ready for october one and we have
asked them to stay on and then continue
using it because they're going to be
much stronger as the true i see 10 and
meaningful use stage 3 comes to the
Federation again I think you know
everything that we have is mapped you
know our problem terminology is probably
our most of you know almost one hundred
percent of our sites use our problem
terminology so as again it's one of the
most important aspects of our
contribution to the marketplace we
identify for every term there may be a
one-to-many in some cases many to many
but there's always a preferred map so
when you guys going to get the activity
and do research on our terminology here
you need to understand is that we always
one preferred map and that preferred map
is there maybe in some cases a charm in
a problem lessness you may have multiple
icd-9 code you know depending on what
the description is but the most
important for our part is we're trying
to capture how the clinicians wants to
talk about their patients and then
capsulate that and for that we identify
preferred method if that map is not
really there's not a coding system
exists we also have our own concept
layer to maintain that to try to manage
and group and internally for management
we map everything to you MLS and mesh in
trying to really create that university
that is connected to our standards of
our country and making sure that those
standards are respected and any
additional investment that we do at the
central locations can be brought up
through our services to that our client
base we we make sure that we bring the
standard organizations to help us you
know you know h IMA which is coding from
in a standard group we support them and
they review every single map that we
have for icd-9 and mcp te activities we
want to make sure that we do not in any
way or any shape do things in vacuum you
know so at least get some sort of cross
map process in place and we believe as
we get connected academic center we also
have some additional stuff you know as
we go into clinical concepts that that
complexity I think is going to be
challenged again and we hope that we can
serve you guys as well as as we do in
serve our iron users we do have a
different definition descriptions for
clinicians new point we have clinician
friendly we have a patient friendly and
we have a coder friendly so we would try
to classify that term in what context
was so if people want to filter those
they can filter it we also have a
specialty concept so by a specialty if
you want to filter by specialty but lot
of this stuff hasn't been really
utilized as well so you could
technically say if I'm cardiologist well
let me let me filter my problem is only
by the cardiology cardiology problems
concepts right there boom now I can see
all the cardiology constable terms in
the problem list you know there's a
multiple ways of looking at it so what
we try to do we try to create the
foundations of so people can do those
kind of
versions at the point of service and
care I mean obviously very familiar with
with these coding sets I think it is
interesting the PCs and CVX and these
other coding aspects have recreated from
challenges for us because many of them
have been really developed in a
different setting and you have am a CPT
and alga pcs connections the spinner it
hasn't been a simple experiment but what
what became most exciting is that we
decided to just go from orders and just
diagnosis to just go to comprehensive
terminology service by making that move
it was a major moving our company that's
basically why our number of staff
doubled you know and and through that
process we actually moved into this
situation where we have over and right
now close to half a million concept and
over 200 2 million interface terms these
are what we manage distribute and the
way that happens is that we get one of
our clients had all their hospital and
all their clients send all their
dictionaries to us and we then
normalized all that and then we created
this universe of terminology management
to allow that normalizations happen and
then then they pushed it back to the
clients and let them do the
reconciliations and management of that
is there unbelievable exciting
opportunity because we're getting to
each user's in the front line involved
and get they becoming far more active
and not only reviewing our stuff but
also participated in icd-10 area we
actually realize things were a little
bit more difficulty story creating these
terminologies to support additional so
called a calculators type of thing so we
developed these calculators and as we
develop these calculators it became it
became very clear that you develop these
calculators and it socially each term
does interview bring the different IC IC
10 descriptions or I say 10 codes but at
same tender for every one of those we
have to map to snowman they have to Napa
to I see I'm yep oh my god guys I mean
it's crazy but four months ago one of
our releases had over 1.1 mil
mapping changes because of all the
activities associated with these cross
mapping so you can tell this very
complex challenge that we had to solve
but what really did it really kind of
turned everybody you know kind of into
understanding the challenge and bringing
about a concept of documenting and
feeling what that documentation is when
you get to the documentation there's a
calculator there's this context of the
calculator and there is a application
that is running the calculator
application so what we try to do our
clients innocent don't let the
application limit you understand the
terminology see what we delivering to
you and then you build your innovation
on top of it don't let the application
kind of handicap you and I think that's
one of the things that is very very
important egh or have their own
limitations they have their own policies
and procedures so we try to educate
everybody so at least they can challenge
their EHRs so if you have the knowledge
let us access it let us deliver it so
really everyone was looking at the Cody
ninety percent of the time at the end of
IC ten was Cody I tell you this delay
nicey tent by year is the best thing
that happened to the clinical aspects of
care you know why because we will not
focus on that dollar anymore we have a
one year during this one you also have a
meaningful use two and three that we
working on so we're going to start
thinking about what is really happening
so doctors enters a term where is it
going the first first time we are
actually thinking that because there's
no way the coders can find all the codes
we bring in the coding process as close
as possible to clinical interface at the
point of care that process is beautiful
opportunity for informatics is the first
time ever this year is the first time
ever that informatics going to be really
truly understood to this day I don't
think anybody understood what it means
informatics what it means to be a
clinician or no computer science what it
means to understand that too is data and
out
versus just a billing so now what
happens you get the code this is what
everybody thinking about we get a you
know we capture the document clinical
content and then voila you get the money
that's all they cared about before but
guys what's really happening we also map
into clinical concept we have in a
snowman infrastructure you when you
really start looking at as a snowman in
structure becomes more and more
sophisticated imagine analytics that you
can do the data that is codified
correctly at least put you know
consistently and that's really exciting
part of the opportunity i think as more
and more these services or understood as
the data is correctly captured that
point of care and in codified then the
researchers in the back can actually
really do some magic which i hope that
we can make that happen for you guys so
what the difference between as there's
another aspects people don't realize
just going to snow matt is not solving
the problem the problem is really is in
context how the terminology is used in
context of pointer care and
documentation you have to understand the
patient's workflow you have to
understand if is in diagnostic space are
being a management phase are we in what
phases are we are we near hpi or in a
review a system or your settlement plan
of your follow up every one of these
every snippet that gets out of the
dictation from physicians has attribute
attached to it those attribute has to be
identified in context so as you retrieve
the information you can retrieve it
better i believe is that what we have in
IMO because we understand electronic
medical record we in addition in
addition if you have created
comprehensive infrastructure for
terminology as map to icy nicey tennis
from SCT we also have created all the
filtering additional filtering grouping
that where they can be used in the
context of documentation in as a chief
complaint you know it's part of HB I is
a past medical history in the surgical
history how that concept is how that
term and the corresponding concept is
related to that documentation is as
important and that is I believe is
another area of innovation
so I think understanding foundation of
EHR means that so how do you then take
that data and now bring this something
more complex and exciting into the
picture well I think providing initially
everybody wants well I want to really
just find my terminology you know tell
me a clinician cannot find it let me
find our ignorance that's how we solved
the first pass we lost time spending you
know searching for terms well you help
them to solve that okay we lost revenue
and organizations well you know we
provide an encoding commissioner be
easier from the revenue and again what
is that one you know see one do one
teach one and this is what me and Bill
been talking about how can we really
bring that to education act know how do
we know what students saw in their
clinical rotations you know can be add
add additional spark to that you know
did he see one or did he see one and do
one or did you see one and then was
participating in teaching one again yeah
all that concept you know becomes a very
exciting opportunity and I think that's
to me is what turns me on I obviously
because that worked at Medical School
for so long because I want really
empower the clinicians and at that point
in time and give given more objective so
this was a meaningful use which really
kind of catapult our services in the
front line people realize they have to
get some there are some money there that
they could collect those money and as we
went to medical unit stage one was easy
for people to do that when you get
number two stage two they realize get
very difficult and telling you three is
going to be even more difficult well
there were some changes you know
obviously suddenly they change to 2014
for immunity then there was this other
one came up I see 10 cm and PCs don't
underestimate pcs is hell okay I mean a
lot of people don't realize they haven't
dig dig deep enough to realize how hard
this stuff is so i think but but anyway
we I think we're responding to those and
then I think bob was dropped obviously
well probably come back again and we'll
know where it's going to come back or as
I admit meaningful use stage 3 is going
to be going backwards or forward or
whatever is going to happen but one
thing is for sure it is opportunity
this is the opportunity to really do
that transformation that are required so
what are we doing review the MU 1 as
really everybody look at it searchable
they were looking at what I'm always
doing and what everybody was in search
of all I want to I see I want a billion
cut off thank God you give me I want my
clinician use my computer give me
billing code so we call searchable
accent okay well what we believe that mu
2 is now become actionable meaning is no
longer it's no longer is just searching
for code and plug it in in you're going
to take some actions you're going to
have to follow some reports some quality
measures regrouping and so on so forth
and again associate without grouping
you're going to be measured so therefore
you're going to take actions and some
workflow activities okay again that's
going to expand informatics humongously
this year I mean if you thought you know
informatics was growing now it's going
to grow much much faster and obviously
analyzable which is really the what I
would call the nirvana and the ultimate
area the whole area of analyzable going
to really make the informatics to become
the most important field in it you know
in health care as well as in the country
around the big data and analytics and
how this done so i think it is an
Innovation Opportunity at each of the
steps but we need to prepare for it you
need to really be ready for it and and
really build not only build education or
build a toolset service what we did we
were distributing our stuffing in end up
mostly as just the data set before
before 19 in everything before about
2009 and then within 2009 we start doing
some technology we said okay how can we
now bring some innovation in technology
and combine that with informatics and
that is what I want to share with you
why I believe that this is a potential
new commerce and could be
so this is how we looked when we
actually were before before 1994 before
2004 now remember we were in business
for 10 years I actually have a wine
bottle says 90 10 years anniversary we
are still with 20 people in still
running around and Lolly informatics a
lot of work we did we build it disease
management system you already saw their
margin glaxo we had all the supper still
things were not moving so we were very
fortunate that we had an innovative
company and understanding their need
associated with the with the market
which is epic decided to take cornell
university book that were doing the
cornell and implemented a pit well when
we did that we very nicely grew nicely
the growth was recognized almost
doubling every year type of thing you
know activity or some percentage growth
we had done yeah but the only thing was
the the linear growth everybody loves a
linear growth but what's happening is is
that it was a fast slow implementations
because you given the data they have to
go to their product and you're importing
exporting revenue recognitions was not
as fast because think about it if if the
clients only get the regulatory updates
or get the one or two obvious a year
some changes that happen in the middle
you know of the transitions discoveries
are not recognized and obviously
installations were and updates were slow
so what happened to us we put that
technology cloud-based technology and we
started distributing cloud this
technology and it would matter of this
is how we looked at that time in less
than two years we just grew it was so
easy majority of the clients just
implement and actually even grow a lot
bigger than this right now and that the
reason is not to say we are resolved
goat is ease of deployment and
implementation so what that really means
is that that understanding allows now us
to bring other innovations and
disseminate it to the same install base
and these install this is not just epic
is not just Cerner is not just analytics
multiple one they're all using the same
foundations
again fast growth fast implementation
fast revenue impact for our clients
clients can see immediately what was
going on what was happening to bring it
to the to bear and obviously a real-time
update you know what I will call just in
time terminology update now we are
working right now with with ohsu and as
one of our first project is we're going
to try to give you access to our our
appliance this is this actual appliance
you know what we call a all of our
terminology is built in there and is
updated regularly and maintains log and
activities and is really can be run on
the cloud and run at the host at a local
level well with the local server would
then connects to the cloud version so
the local version breaks any researchers
works out can sail over to the cloud
version so we probably want to start
with the cloud version and and the way
is a structured right now it's it's
really with just just with the these are
all appliance sites in less than a year
that's how many apply inside we
implemented this is in top of what we
showed you before and these are at
locations in the client and then we have
these what we call services around the
country that failover I normally don't
talk about this in academic talk because
our objective is to make sure you
understand that when the appliance that
you're getting in in what kind of
network you're plugging yourself into
you plug in yourself into the network
about the clinic all the other other
site and we are collecting all the terms
our search what's going on in many cases
we can actually identify outbreaks you
know a couple weeks you know before
others because we can see how the
physician our internet and obviously
they'll be filtering the between
academic searches as well as the
physician point-of-care searches these
are all anonymize again is another
another opportunity for research we were
talking an hour ago what can other work
we can do this is another poor area that
you guys can tap into and look at what
searches people are doing and how you
want to utilize that is in your
structure or some of the water you doing
with your community here now so semantic
highway really basically is the
real-time pathway to messaging
based on medical concept so that's what
I'm view it so imagine it is that being
able to as it documents go true to know
what they're talking about and how
original and based on that what they're
talking about to be able to have things
trigger that to me is what I'm defining
a semantic hi so again we increase
domain coverage and and what we learned
is that you know as we go into next
level is that there is there's
opportunity to engage everybody else
around us so what we have to do to
manage that there's not enough in
formatted sis in a country to be able to
help us okay so we have to engage your
client themself to actually help us to
manage their own terminology so we
created a very elaborate migration
services which is the declines send us
the documents we push the documents true
or our service automatic matching and
then we have this workflow that they go
through as they go through that workflow
you know it's a multiple-step multiple
processes then within the process is
done we basically bring it back and then
we have created another cloud-based
service for them to connect and
reconciliate their determinant
dictionaries during that process they
can challenge what our mapping was what
their system was and also they can now
they can now actually say oh give me the
damn my dashboard of all my dictionaries
and how do I relate to other
dictionaries again another area that we
can you know have you guys work with us
is the whole concept here is is that
being understanding the addictions are
using the death sites gives the DNA of
that site okay that DNA will tell you
what they can and cannot do or what they
can report on what it cannot report on
and now now you can only create a
mapping and so called matching between
site to site to see what they ever buy
do to get together again this is where
you're very excited about this but it's
growing so fast that we have to know
we're trying to really now get some
massive Oracle appliances to try to help
us we try to use everything so most
important part is when beginning new
terms that someone says you
want to map it we get that term and
within six week we try to get that term
into the corpus obviously every term
that we map doesn't find its way in the
corpus we have we have for the 42
million terms that we have we have maybe
about five million description that you
know a lot of them don't find a servant
or frontline but they're sitting in our
corpus for for evaluation so as soon as
we map the terms or something we have we
keep track of that now we to get to that
is not available on the appliance but to
get that if you get some research here
we can connect you to those data as well
so you can see the NLP natural language
processing or our concept tagger
actually does that get access to it for
you so again this is how we bring it up
so let's talk about innovation this is a
dictation a simple dictations about a 50
year old patient and it was a basically
a one-paragraph this you know a couple
paragraph descriptions about a patient's
visiting and and so we use this as as
part of our when we open our office in
champaign we brought non computer
science no non-medical people and
interested in informatics together to
put together this innovation challenge
and you have the challenge and almost a
hackathon type of thing actually we have
another hackathon coming next week we
have 700 students from all different
schools coming to champagne and we
actually give another challenge to them
for that hackathon but this one was
around this case and it's okay students
tell us what's what you're learning
about this how can you understand how do
you what's going on with this patient
and basically what it came down to is
that they worked out and everyone try to
come up with what we learn is that
there's all these concept or existed in
those in that case and you can get the
XML of it and then what we then created
created structural anshel aspects so
within that one paragraph there were
discussions on five different or six
different episode of the patient care so
the question was they suddenly realize
it was much more complex situation
that complexity that complexity taught
him oh my god what an opportunity to
working informatics by the way out of
dollar dose group of students who
competed almost eighty percent of them
work for me right now okay so that
excitement of knowing wow there's so
much more to do every one of these arrow
that you say there is still another new
innovations nobody has done it yet I
said this potential discovery being able
to understand and then bring that result
back either prospectively or
retrospectively to the patient here
there was multiple episode associate
with it first you know for purpose time
I'm not going to go into much detail in
this I think that we can as part of
follow-up I think you know we have this
NLP infrastructures where you can test
the different kind of NLP using our
terminology we can you know set up
another session just going through this
kind of detail but what is important is
that we took the tix the text and
information model and that information
model identified items within the face
sheet and how the face sheet
transformation was happening how a
problem came into the fish it was at
part of differential diagnosis how was
ruled in or ruled out and how that
followed up happened and I was cared for
how you became the focus of the
management again then justified a
potential particular procedures should
be done or not based on a patient
history okay again these are these are
part of the things that people don't
realize when you have a clinicians
involved and the clinicians reads the
chart and analyze a chart and gives you
a paragraph summary that's the gold mine
that's the gold that's what you want to
grab on to that's what we need
informatics to be able to understand and
connect to that and bring it on chart in
the parcel out and then really create
that personal analysis or or tagging of
that data in a way that becomes there
forever more important than many other
data point that you have in the chart
again so what that says to you it
doesn't mean you have to have a very
fancy your chart to be able to
port some you know informatics
innovations you just need to understand
who the audience is where is it being
performed and what is it for and that
contextual aspect is becoming more and
more important in a care of the patients
and how the technology is used again
this is the next generation innovation
concept discovery are basically tagging
and NL and natural language processing I
tell you guys I am so disappointed with
what I have seen in the market in
natural language was so disappointed all
they do find NM codes or get you to I c9
color say 10 ko's for reimbursement guys
I mean that's that I mean we really need
to do more we can do lot more we can do
better and i think that's iono think
again the IC 10 delay can give us
opportunity to do that do lab more than
just that's easy getting to the coding
system that's just too it something more
exciting anyway so I see applied
informatics innovations and adding that
to longitudinal care record architecture
is by far the next generation many and
understand what is captured as you're
building your database or data warehouse
model be aware of that stuff and and
every year every year every six months
or every terminology update reevaluate
your Darryl data warehouse let's face it
guys knowledge changes every day you got
to be able to rerun the stuff over and
over and over and be able to challenge
whatever you have whatever how fast have
you had I think it's going to be so
exciting it's going to be nothing but
continuous discovery continues discovery
as you build your data warehouse and I
think vendors are doing that right now
we are very excited to work epic is
doing we're very excited with many
texturing and certainly do all the
vendors are becoming very very conscious
of that and being able to support their
solutions as well as academic solutions
and independent solutions again I think
the biggest inhibition of 21st
century will be at the intersection of
biology and technology and new era is
beginning I truly believe that
experience that a steve job went through
on its last year of his life really made
him realize how important was you know
there was not a rule as in medicine is
really medicine you know we can really
do and I think he is really exciting
part for us is to not take that to heart
and I think I have to say I I raised
with the Steve lifestyle you know I mean
you know I was a massive computer
science master program in 1975 you know
doing this type of Apple coming out and
everything else going up in Microsoft so
I've been living in this technology as
evolution but have always had my eyes in
healthcare I think they're right now in
that health care where we can have the
steve job of the world of a healthcare
and informatics come about and I'm
looking forward to support your
department to make that happen really I
think to connect research and research
centers to the point of care we need to
expand the standards like sno-med CT to
classify medical education and research
topics around the same concept that are
using the front line if you have
multiple concept multiple definitions in
LCA me my monitor is one way this
dictionary dis dictionaries and each
department have their own dictionaries
and their own cost of the man let's
bring them together let's just kind of
connect them somehow someway I believe
it's going to really bring opportunity
for us I think to succeed in semantic
base Commerce we need a semantic grade
we need those trusted outpost we need
those messengers that will go from
academic center to challenge the
semantic highway challenge these
companies like IMO challenge companies
like any EHR vendors to say are you
doing it right what are you missing what
you're not delivering I think it is not
like Facebook is not like Twitter this
is not that kind of growth this requires
academic foundations to really challenge
the front line I believe that's very
very important to be able to understand
and create that grid that is really
truly connects academic standards to
your frontline I believe what work that
we're trying to do with
with your team here is again around that
whole issue to make sure you can
challenge us and what we are delivering
in the front line again we need to
empower the clinicians and researchers
so their innovation can be marketed and
use in real time we are semantically so
if the discovery happening ideas come up
you're doing a data warehouse analytics
you say hello there is a relationship
between this particular findings or this
particular problem and this patient and
then this could be generalizable we did
a analysis oda analysis on on the HIV
population in Africa and we found out B
complex vitamins was a major factor to
keep in his people alive another 45
years because a lot of them were not
taking vitamins in some of this original
African traditions when we did the work
with their glaxo wellcome when they were
working on the cocktail treatment for
HIV we were able to demonstrate that if
you administered their medications first
in a cocktail treatment was a better
outcome okay the question here is these
discoveries can almost immediately
become bring value to the front line and
that's why I hope that we can get to it
okay through a partnership between
academic care delivery and vendor
community we can make the world flat for
I a chai tea but really I have a heading
agenda and I'm going to be truthful with
that I really would love to make us a
destination health care for a world I
think we have the best academic centers
best medicine is just we just have to
make it happen and we can make it happen
thank you very much
question so we have time time for some
questions and as everyone knows we push
these buttons so because we're recording
this and I don't see any questions
coming over the twitter feed what one of
the i'm curious on your thoughts on this
I mean I you know I fully accept buy
into your vision of sort of normalizing
the semantics of health care one of the
problems with data that gets collected
in clinical settings is that you know
clinicians are busy they have other
things on their mind they just want to
get through doing their documentation
that there's also a lot of complaints
which you may well know of the data
entry how difficult maybe not difficult
but time consuming data entry is and
electronic health records have you guys
given any thought to that problem and
then respond to it okay so we have
otherwise our logs on our portal it
takes about 2.7 seconds for condition to
find the finding the right binding so
2.7 seconds and one of this is not found
the first time it takes three searches
but occurs in about seven seconds okay
simple so I think that's from search
test from searchable okay so when you go
to action it was a little bit different
so I think I do have a dream and then
the dream that i have is really the sole
physician community where they connected
to the academic center to some sort of
mechanism where all their activities is
harvested in a way that they can then
bring those activities and then review
it and then basically learn upon that i
think if we get a somehow make it a more
proactive model what that really means
is very simply this is that the logs
that we're creating that we just such as
articulated to has an identifier if we
because we have that feature if the
users identify the providers who was
actually using that service and trigger
that right at the point service that
becomes a source of opportunity for them
to go back to see what
done majority of docs I mean my wife I
am not kidding you guys I mean it is
every time she went to surgeon night
before sheds nightmares and the middle
of nightmares and I keep the time too so
what's going on was kind i forgot the
suture whatever they say i'm sure same
some medical stuff I do understand but
well and she's actually that that
concern so is just that's pre surgery
and then a post-surgery same thing and I
have not what's going on I gotta go to
hospital I get a glass of what's going
to I gotta go check the stick so the
question here is there are so
conscientious there are so conscientious
we just need to give them better tools
we need to create these activities are
happening with them within an epic
within the Cerner within a meditech
within every day everywhere they touch
we should be to be able to bring them
together so we can give them some some
new innovation I don't know what that
looks like I'm sure somebody else to
come up with it but I will tell you that
is what I see the opportunity and I'll
tell you when when the institution when
the application or software application
things that takes that intent and
convert it to something else and store
something else that's by far the biggest
violation biggest violation to our
future you cannot change that you got to
keep that so we can then give back that
positions opportunity to better
themselves because they always want to
better themselves they answer your
questions I mean IIIi think I say just
take a 1 a step higher you know just
just go go to the moon I mean there's a
war on there were on the moon now so you
know it can line it yes sir alluding to
what what bill just mentioned we're
building a in ontology in the head neck
area in maxillofacial and as we look to
building registries and using our
structured data to answer clinical
questions we realized that the the
information in the health record is
fragmented and you know has a lot of
semantic challenges and as you mentioned
in your talk what's what's pure gold is
the structured information and
if you can one the biggest we see two
big challenges in front in finding large
databases of structured information and
that's getting busy clinicians to enter
it in ways that a machine can understand
and then also having it centralized so
if you have collections of data we still
face the challenge that you're real
you're only going to get the data from
your institution unless you have an IR
in institutional review board approval
so for rare entities that I as a
clinician may see five times you know
every decade to find the answers to
those we need we need collections of
data that are able to cross institutions
to cross providers to cross styles of
treatment and and to get rid of all the
variables of round treatment that can
affect an outcome and really see what's
happening but so just the first thing I
I do it for your concern and that's why
the outpost or trusted outpost has
typical academic centers you know we
need to first and foremost create a
semantic grid between academic center so
they can become the who they really
should be you know police's of these
these so-called cross-pollination you
know as we move these this activity to
the front line by these vendors who a
computer science guy like myself is
running the company it does not extend
medicine you know it becomes Aurelia I
mean obviously have a little bit more
experience because I was my wife is a
doctor but this but doesn't this a make
me a doctor now and you need to be able
to have some sort of mechanism where we
can bring that activities that are
analytics to some sort validation
process within the Makah demonstrator
the least common denominator is
normalization terminology so you say you
do an ontology right now we're neck and
head well make sure that ontology
'you've building has a map you know
using I'm addiction as foundations so
now suddenly that ontology is a multiple
aspects of that on television there's a
descriptions of the ontology and then
there's a relationship among those on
the charms
the relation is among the term is the
gold the ontology management is going to
change you wanna make sure have a
foundation that you can trust on so when
you build something you can then trust
it now when you trusted in that XML
format that whatever format a portable
format that you have and if that
portable form and now can then be
transmitted to the universe other
academic center can use it as well I can
test it or it can be packaged to market
it for some so-called I risk based
institutions who feel that what you have
done is going to help for them managing
the risk population and save money
that's what we need I know by the way
you should be rewarded for it you should
be the next Steve Jobs or you know i'm
serious we should have our academics i
reported that upside anyway that's my
made that answer your question yes it
did you know and we obviously use
sno-med as the as per kafil for what we
did but we found that in in clinical
findings only about what fifty percent
of the forty percent of clinical
findings that we've decided are very
important for clinicians exist in
sno-med my domain and only about thirty
percent of procedures that my fellow
domain experts do exist in assume it
well I think that's what I think it
would be awesome for you to see what we
have now what we have done we have done
exact opposite we have first gone to the
clinicians and see what they're using
and then model in this moment we have to
be found the same problem the snowman so
what would we would we feel that there
are some because of some of the post
coordination is associated with some of
the hierarchies existence nomad we
couldn't rely on it so we made sure
there's a map to the snow Matt hierarchy
but we did not limit the terms because
it was not could not be modeled in this
moment so I think maybe you know that
could be one project you know you guys
can look at what we have you know see if
that model helps you and there may be
things you're doing that I can bring to
my clients you know right now just an
ontology area so at least you know that
they can use it correctly because you
are the expert you know what's going on
with your domain and if I can take your
understanding to the role community in
in Omaha that's great you know then that
doctor is going to become better so now
you that's my that's how I feel yes sir
a while back you showed this interesting
tree of how you structured data within
clinical narrative I was wondering did
you do that manually or did you have
your technology generate that structure
no this was done manually there's done
mostly manually but with Bobby showed we
showed we use that to show different NLP
and what I didn't help we can do some
NLP can our date sensitive they can
understand understand the date sense it
some can just tag it with just concept
Bates so so what we have to do the
project was really to understand the
complexity after you understood
complexity then say what can inhibition
can you come up with which one of those
it can you solve with our innovations we
just want to add to that absolutely the
concept of time is very poorly
understood what we're very good at is
understanding the the way did I is build
using marginal care records but frankly
fitting that Modell with an NLP engine
is premature and the herd up and I've
not seen anybody doing that and we
pretty much have access to all in LP
engine available in the world dirty I
just found it interesting because if you
could generate that structure
automatically would we need to compare
it across different sites for
collaborative purposes because then you
can see serve what cognitive model does
someone have here versus what cognitive
hours so III even even better than that
better than that even if you can do
minor aspects of that where a physician
does a summary just compare that with
the EMR data that you have that what the
EMR says that patient has just within
that organization that in itself is an
unbelievable opportunity to help that
emot even make their structures better
and their data better because that's
really you know it's amazing how some of
the historical data are gets elevated to
importance which was really was not
supposed to you know something that was
resolved the problem that was resolved
that it's still dangling in the image
art and talk about credit score oh my
god when we turn on our you know our
terminology within the within the
consumer terms you know vanilla our
patient portal for our vendor partners
we suddenly realized some of our
description that we gave to some of
these diagnoses were actually not good
so when we tell everybody said you
talked to the patients you're talking
they're really the commander in chief of
their help okay so you you want to make
sure whatever doctor says should be
there and whatever patient you translate
should be there at the same time so a
lot of that patient make that decisions
and I think I'll tell you they're just
so much more to be done even within the
process of physician documentation eh
art storage and the patient review if
you can get the patient into the
equations and then pick that chart and
then actually make sure they understand
it and they know their responsibility
it's just a lot of stuff you right i
mean you can do the cross one but if you
do a cross when it is little bit too
far-fetched you know i mean because you
know we really haven't we haven't you
know we had a crawl before we know yeah
the difficulty but graph and getting
people to comprehend just what the hell
is happening here was to for people to
understand from paragraph three boys are
actually the advance but should be
modeled on the graph and what should be
shown on a face sheet over time over six
events in time that's what I should see
as a as a provider or as a computer
science person trying to model the data
and organized by using terminology and
computer science simply enough that is
actually hard enough before we do but to
donate it